oil tankers go up in flames in the
Middle East a million people take to the
streets in Hong Kong as China tightens
its grip over the formerly westernized
region and President Trump appears to
endorse campaign collusion and foreign
election interference in an interview
with George Stephanopoulos we will
examine foreign policy threats and faux
pas then Jordan Peterson launches a new
social media platform deep fakes blur
the distinction between fiction and
reality with serious implications for
2020 and finally after all that a
mailbag I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do we have a busy show today but first
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer you know about ring up and telling
you about ring for a long time they have
their smart video doorbells they have
their cameras that protect millions of
people everywhere in the world and most
importantly they let you feel like
you're living in the future or the
Jetsons or something ring helps you stay
connected to your home anywhere in the
world so if there's a package delivery
or if there's a surprise visitor you
know anything from your mother-in-law to
a burglar I don't know which one you'd
be happier to see you will get an alert
and be able to see hear and speak to
them all from your phone because of the
amazing HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices the thing I
really like about this too is that ring
uploads all the video to the cloud so
even if you've got a really smart robber
who realizes he's even to steal your
ring device he like rips it out of the
wall or something you already got the
video so you can catch the guy our
senior producer Jonathan hey just the
other day as was a couple months ago now
he was sleeping it's 3:00 in the morning
and his lovely home and he gets a ring
on his Bell it's these drug addled
wackos who were casing the joint trying
to rob him he responds to them he could
have been anywhere in the world but he
was in his bed and he chases them away
they run away as a listener right now
you have a special offer on a ring a
starter kit available with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home and it's just
super cool this is why I give it to my
friends as a housewarming gift go to
ring.com slash knowles kenda wles
ring comm slash knowles now before we
get to foreign threats in Asia and the
Middle East we have to turn our
attention to a foreign threat that has
already invaded our country by checking
in on the Women's World Cup with our
daily wire to sports correspondent
Jeremy the god-king borings yeah
Michael it's that time of year again
time for the Federation of
something-something soccer of America
world cup and this time Michael there's
ladies for those of you who don't
remember because you're American the
World Cup is that special tournament
we're in grown adult athletes from every
corner of the earth even terribly poor
countries and oppressive countries
gather
once a year to determine who has taken
soccer that cute game beloved by
toddlers and elementary school children
everywhere and have managed somehow
against all odds to build a team that
can score one two possibly two points
nor than all of the other teams and thus
be declared the very best at something
which for women's teams means being just
slightly worse than an above-average
troop of 15 year old boys that's not an
exaggeration Michael look it up it's
also that special time of year when
Democrats in the news media collude with
one another to obstruct justice that
sacred state in which individuals
receive exactly that to which they are
entitled by demanding that female soccer
players be paid the same as their male
counterparts this despite the fact that
no one watches them buys their products
attends their events or even knew their
silly little sport existed until they
made headlines for whining about their
pay and disrespecting our nations flag
female soccer players work just as hard
as male soccer players the pundits
shriek as though the level of effort one
puts into a task determines the amount
other people are willing to trade in
return for the service and as if male
soccer players actually work harder than
America's blue-collar laborers who toil
in obscurity for less than 75 K and just
want to be watch just want to watch
baseball and be left the hell alone of
course and the interest of true justice
Michael we here at the Daily wire to
looked into the accusations that there
is indeed unfairness in the system and
we have discovered this shocking truth
according to a reporter at our sister
network The Daily wire women's soccer
brought in 17 million dollars in ad
revenue in 2015 men's soccer by contrast
generated 31 times that amount the
previous Women's World Cup which
America's ladies won generated 73
million in revenue worldwide the men's
world cup also known as the world cup
grossed upwards of 6 billion yes Michael
that's billion with a B a full 82 times
more than the more homely female
counterparts and yet the women's team
received 10 million dollars for their
trouble 13% Michael of the total hall
whereas the men's team only received 6
percent of the 6 billion dollar haul
from the men's world
so you can see Michael it's true foul
injustice has occurred the men are
clearly paid less than they deserve
somebody get me a penis hat hey Michael
hey Michael
penis at anyway it probably won't matter
much law it probably won't matter much
longer as this is likely the last World
Cup in which players who were born
biologically female will ever win the
sport since they're being replaced as in
all other women's sports by mediocre
male athletes looking for an easy win
and willing to suffer for their craft
this because not a single left-wing
politician media figure or academic can
produce a working definition of the word
woman but how overpaid female athletes
are isn't the only controversy from
women's soccer Michael Mary ropes Pierre
something captain of the American
national team has decided to forego the
entire premise of a national team a team
that represents a nation in an
international competition and refuses to
participate in the national anthem of
the nation that her national team
represents which is this nation America
with a well practiced resting [ __ ]
that would be a terrible cliche if she
were a lesbian Mary Rorschach test
proved that there is in fact an AI and
team and a couple of other letters to
boot by glaring into the middle distance
while a 96 year old veteran of World War
two harmonica Pete played the
star-spangled banner from his wheelchair
of course the ride of dour entitled
white women to virtue signal by shunning
their nation's banner and heroes before
they engage in a children's sport for
money and fame is exactly what the
heroes of World War two were fighting
for right Michael right of course it
wasn't Michael they were fighting for
national pride to avenge those murdered
and the vicious sneak attack on our
forces at Pearl Harbor to preserve their
uniquely Christian and unregulated and
free way of life to defend our allies to
stop the Germans from their second
attempt in half a century to dominate
the entire globe and for their brothers
beside them doing the same are you
kidding
if these guys could have seen the
disgrace that is Mary Robocop snarling
at harmonica Pete's 75 years after they
stormed the beaches of Normandy and the
praise she received from our national
media for the
to their honor they probably would have
called the whole thing off and told us
their grandchildren and
great-grandchildren enjoy speaking
German kids and playing soccer like the
Germans the Nazis love soccer
yeah ah Michael back to you Jeremy a
very thorough report I have only one
question that you didn't cover when it
is the ladies who are playing the soccer
game themselves who drives the minivans
to pick them up when the practice and
the games are over Michael in this day
and age in which men have completely
forfeited their role in society and in
the family you can bet that beta men all
over this country will happily pick up
their ladies in minivans and SUVs I look
forward to going out and buying the
juice boxes later Jeremy the god-king
boring the sports correspondent for our
sister network daily yeah a really
thorough report that was that was
terrific I can't wait for the World Cup
to happen again next year this is going
to be just terrific we've got to talk
about less dangerous threats from abroad
to our country I speak of course of oil
tankers blowing up in the Middle East
and riots happening in Hong Kong in the
Middle East right now that too oil
tankers have been hit by shells or
torpedoes we don't know which this left
one of the tankers on fire this left one
of them just sort of floating adrift
this is one month after four oil tankers
in the region were sabotage in Port and
this this two attack today happened in
the Gulf of Oman which I've actually
visited I was seeing a friend in Dubai
and we rented a car and drove down to
Muscat Oman which is right on the Gulf
of Oman and I can tell you from just
first-hand experience this is not a
place that you want to be it's very nice
country Oman but it's surrounded by very
dangerous countries you have on the one
side Saudi Arabia which is a US ally on
the other side you have the United Arab
Emirates which is another US ally across
the water you've got Iran that is not a
US ally that's a u.s. foe and then on
the last part of the border with Oman
you have a Yemen which is now in a civil
war and the civil war is actually just a
proxy war between Saudi Arabia
and Iran backing different sides this is
where Oman is smushed in the world and
so everyone is suspecting that this oil
tanker was blown up by Iran we don't
know we're not sure the foreign minister
of Iran
John Kerry's good buddy Javed Sharif I
think his name is something like that
he says it's very suspicious it's very
curious of course it is if it were Iran
that wouldn't make a ton of sense right
now the reason for that is that one of
the tankers that got blown up was a
Japanese tanker and the Prime Minister
of Japan Shinzo Abe a just landed in
Iran as the first time a Japanese Prime
Minister has gone to Iran since 1979 so
this is supposed to be a big moment for
peace and progress in the region
wouldn't make a whole lot of sense for
Iran to do it however on the other hand
it maybe would make the most sense
because it gives Iran a lot of cover no
one would be expecting them to do that
at this time so perhaps that's exactly
when they would strike so you have Iran
saying that the timing benefits us the
United States and Saudi Arabia American
allies because it it gives us leverage
in these heightened tensions in the
region then you have on the other hand
we say the timing benefits Iran because
it gives them cover the broader context
of this is there's been talk of the
United States going to war with Iran for
some months now there's been talk about
this for years because Iran is
developing a nuclear weapon and the
national security adviser to Donald
Trump has advocated war with Iran for a
long time I love the guy John Bolton but
when they were negotiating the so-called
Iran deal John Bolton had an op-ed I
think in The New York Times that said to
stop Iran's bomb bomb Iran and so you
every every aspect of this looks
suspicious
this is there is no conclusion anyone
who tells you there's an easy conclusion
from what's going on right now in the
Middle East is is lying to you we don't
know what's happening we don't know the
prospect of war with Iran we know that
President Trump Iran is an anti-war
candidate he doesn't want to go to war
with
Ronnie's been resisting advisors who
have been trying to get him to go to war
with Iran and so we'll see if this puts
him over the edge
or if he's gonna stick to his guns here
on the other side of the world we've got
some trouble in Hong Kong but first let
me tell you why I feel so good and
rested you know why it is it's because
of purple mattress the greatest bed I've
ever slept in that you need to go get
right now it will feel different than
anything you have ever experienced
because it's this new brand new material
it was developed by rocket scientists
it's not an innerspring like an old
mattress it's not quite a memory foam
like some of those newer cheaper
mattresses this thing is unbelievable
I was super skeptical of it because they
say it's firm and soft at the same time
how is that possible I don't know but it
is they say it sleeps cool it doesn't
get you too hot at night how is that
possible I don't know but that's true so
that I get this bed I almost didn't want
to move out my old innerspring bed I
said I don't know maybe I don't know if
I want to try that I'm very particular
about my bed I spent 19 to 24 hours a
day in it so I've tried out for one
night I was immediately sold I threw out
my old bed I have not looked back I'm
recommending this to all of my friends
you are going to love it you got a
hundred night risk-free trial if you're
not fully satisfied you can return your
mattress for a full refund but you'll
you won't want to do that it's backed by
a 10-year warranty free shipping and
returns free in-home set up an old
mattress removal the thing is just
correct kid you not I wake up in the
morning and I tell sweet little ELISA ah
I feel so good on my purple mattress
what did we do before the purple
mattress it's it's that good I don't
know how else to convey it to you you
got to try it yourself right now you're
my listeners rather will get a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress that's in addition to the great
free gifts that they're offering
site-wide how do you do it
pull out your phone if you're driving
pull over pull out your phone text
Knolls que no wles to eight four eight
eight eight that is the only way to get
this free purple pillow tex Knolls KO
wles to eight four eight eight eight KO
wles to eight four eight eight eight
message and data rates may apply on the
other side of the world right now over
in Hong Kong upwards of a million people
have taken to the
streets to protest a new bill that would
allow extradition 'z to mainland China
so ostensibly what this is about is if
someone commits a crime in China they
can go away to run to Hong Kong and then
they won't be extradited that's not
really what this is about what this is
really about is China tightening its
grip over a semi-autonomous region known
as Hong Kong Hong Kong is is the fourth
most densely populated region in the
world this is a an international City a
center of global finance very
westernized city and it's separate it's
a separate administrative region of
China which has its own governing and
economic systems for now but China is
encroaching on that the people there
don't identify as Chinese they identify
as Hong Kongers and how did Hong Kong
get to be so great while China's a
terrible country it got to be so great
because the British ruled it for 150
years so if this was from the end of the
First Opium War in 1842 through 1997 not
that long ago Britain controlled Hong
Kong and it was great it was awesome by
the end of the 19th century
I guess 1898 Britain signed a 99-year
lease with China for Hong Kong's I said
99 years we're gonna give this region
back unfortunately during that time
period you had the Communist revolution
you had Mao destroy the entire country
and for some reason Britain still
honored the Treaty and gave Hong Kong
back which it probably shouldn't have
done so you have this essentially
western city that is crumbling under
Chinese rule now China is clamping down
even more on this and obviously this has
a lot to do with the United States trade
war with China I mean that you can't
take out this fully largely westernized
global financial center right there in
China it's kind of between the East and
the West China tightening its grip you
can't take that out of the context of
the major trade war that the United
States is finally admitting we're
already in with China China stealing our
IP illegally subsidizing steel and
aluminum violating WTO treaties spying
on us put
spyware in the technology that they
produce for us this is a major issue and
so they're clamping down on Hongkong
what does this have to do with the
United States what this has to do with
the United States is that you've got
tankers going up in flames in the Middle
East you've got a clamping down on a
westernized and important financial city
just outside of China and a bad side of
mainland China and then you've got
President Trump for some reason agreeing
to do an interview with former Clinton
operative George Stephanopoulos in the
Oval Office and he totally puts his foot
in his mouth on foreign policy here's
what he said before the Senate
Intelligence Committee met today and
again he was not charged with anything
in retrospect that way not only wasn't
he charged if you read it with all of
the horrible fake news I mean I was
reading that my son was gonna go to jail
this is a good young man that he was
gonna go to jail
don't you need have been caught up in
the rush investigation because of that
Trump Tower meeting in 2016 which he set
up expecting to get dirt on Hillary
Clinton from the Russian government okay
let's put yourself in a position you're
a congressman somebody comes up and says
hey I have information on your opponent
do you call the FBI I don't think I mean
from anyone you do I've seen a lot of
things over my life I don't think in my
whole life I've ever called the FBI in
my whole life I don't you don't call the
FBI life says if we have the director
says that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong because frankly it
doesn't happen like that okay so so far
you see what Stephanopoulos is doing
he's setting it up and his talk is
getting Donald Trump into this personal
territory because Don junior ostensibly
set up that Russia meeting at Trump
Tower and so there were all these
threats that they're gonna throw Don
junior in prison so Stephanopoulos gets
Trump on this very defensive very
personal ground should your son go to
prison did your son break the law did he
do something wrong
so Trump obviously very loyal especially
to his kids he says no way they didn't
do anything wrong this is completely
fine if someone came up to you and said
we've got dirt on your opponent
obviously you take the meeting and by
the way everybody in the country would
take that meeting it's not just Donald
Trump if someone says I got dirt on your
opponent you're running for office you
take it you of course you take the
meeting now he veers off into bad
territory and says the FBI director is
wrong absolute no I wouldn't have called
the FBI maybe you need a more delicate
answer here he's saying no campaign
would have called the FBI maybe that's
true I mean in the case of the Hillary
Clinton 2016 campaign not only it's not
that she was offered dirt and she called
the FBI too reported the Clinton
campaign worked with the FBI through
proxies to spy on the Trump campaign the
Hillary Clinton campaign paid for the
steel dossier which was used as the
bogus evidence to get the Obama
administration to spy on the Trump
campaign they were it's it's almost like
an inverse of what they're accusing
Trump of doing here but even so far what
Trump is saying is sort of defensible
then he goes too far this time around if
foreigners if Russia if China if someone
else offers you information on opponents
should they accept it or should they
call the FBI I think maybe you do both I
think you might want to listen I don't
there's nothing wrong with listening if
somebody called from a country Norway we
have information on your opponent oh I
think I'd want to hear if you want that
kind of interference in our elections
it's not an interference they have
information I think I'd take it this was
a total setup question I mean a really
tough question to be in from
Stephanopoulos and president Trump blew
it it's a bad look to say yeah I want
foreign governments to give me dirt on
my opponents you don't want to encourage
them to give you dirt on your opponents
because then you would the foreign
governments and by the way Trump didn't
do this he's putting himself into this
hypothetical situation that he's going
to be criticized for that he didn't even
do he is it's just a bad political look
because now the left and the anti Trump
right are in hysterics and they're
saying he's not a patriot and he's a
traitor to his country that's not the
issue the actual thing he's talking
about isn't even the issue every country
interferes in every other country's
elections country is interfere with each
other they do it all the time during the
Obama administration Barak Obama sent
his senior campaign aides
to Israel to try to oust Benjamin
Netanyahu from power
he sent 350,000 dollars of US taxpayer
money to a front organization to oust
Bibi Netanyahu from power in Israel we
all interfere in each other's elections
still what you don't want is for the
President of the United States to accept
this sort of thing publicly to accept
these premises publicly because what it
does invariably is create the impression
of disloyalty to your country that's the
impression the president Trump is giving
off he's saying yeah I'm I would totally
accept the help of foreign governments I
would incentivize foreign governments to
give me dirt on American politicians now
he's not actually doing it and actually
Democrat politicians have done this they
have gone and colluded with foreign
governments to try to win elections Ted
Kennedy colluded with the Soviet Union
to try to win the presidency this is how
he was negotiating with the Soviet Union
to help him get elected so it does
happen but what so why don't you say it
you don't say it because hypocrisy is
the tribute that vice pays to virtue
because you don't you also don't want to
create incentives publicly speaking you
don't want to put out on your bullhorn
and say hey foreign governments of the
world give me dirt on my opponents
please spy on American citizens spy on
American politicians it's just a bad
look the good thing you can say for
president Trump in this interaction is
something that I've said for a long time
which is that President Trump is the
most honest president that we've ever
had he is he's call him honest Donald
you have Honest Abe now you can have
honest Donald why is he the most honest
president because President Trump brags
about doing all the bad things and
thinking all the bad things that all the
other presidents have also done but
they've hidden he's open about it he's
honest about it obviously any any
politic what he said is practically true
if you're even the president or you're
running a campaign and someone comes up
to you and says we got dirt on your
opponent let's say it's some norwegian
lawyer maybe he's got ties to the
Weejun government he says I got a ton of
dirt on your opponent 100% of political
campaigns take that meeting and take the
dirt they hear him out as Trump said
maybe they call the FBI after maybe they
don't who knows 100 percent of campaigns
do it only this guy would actually admit
to wanting to do that or to actually
doing that in some ways this is
refreshing I actually do think this has
some positive effect on our political
discourse because it just knocks away so
much B s so much preening falsehood
however what this also means is then we
need to articulate that it's bad you
don't want to incentivize foreign
governments to spy on American citizens
even if they're awful American citizens
like Hillary Clinton you don't want to
incentivize that you don't want it to
seem like the President of the United
States is encouraging you to do that or
offering you something in return that's
not a good idea it's refreshing to hear
a guy speak honestly but then it's
incumbent on all the rest of us to say
right true that is honest we shouldn't
do that don't do it
moving on to some good news happening
domestically Jordan B Peterson you know
the lobster king himself he's announcing
a new social media platform this is
going to be a censorship free platform
this is going to be a platform that
conservatives are welcomed to he
announced the name of it it is called
think spot now what does it do it will
allow creators to monetize their content
it will be radically Pro free speech
they say the only way they're going to
take someone off is if a court orders
them to and so this creates some
problems creates a because the trouble
with these is the minute that you set up
a social media platform a new one and
you say it's gonna be Pro free speech
you just get flooded with the Nazis and
so it becomes the Nazi platform now one
way they're working on this is the the
platform is going to require a minimum
of 50 words per post and I love this
idea because what that means is even if
you're just going to troll in Jordan
Peterson sports you have to be a witty
troll you have to use your brain you
have to use words you have to offer some
even sort of vaguely
substantive idea I like that so is it
going to work if anybody can make this
work it's Jordan Peterson because he's
just a superstar right now he is
acceptable to conservatives and liberals
not not the hard left but some liberals
he's acceptable to religious people and
secular people I mean he's embraced by
Bishop Baron Catholic bishop
he's also ambition braced by the whole
materialist new-agey secular crowd and
he infuriates the censorship crowd so
he's got the right enemies for that big
problem that we mentioned Nazis he does
have a system for this the system is
that if you if you basically if you get
ratioed then your posts are hidden and
people can click on it and see them but
they're not they don't automatically pop
up and so the New York Times or New York
magazine rather is referring to this as
shadow banning they say Jordan
Peterson's Pro free speech pad product
forum is going to be just as bad on
shadow banning as Twitter and all the
others or that's not true that's
completely dishonest what what Jordan is
describing is not shadow banning what
he's saying is if you get down voted too
many times more than 50% of the time
your post isn't going to show up that's
kind of like reddit that's not shadow
banning we all know the rules we all
know what's happening you the user you
the content creator can see that what
shadow banning is is when they don't
tell you that you're not showing up in
timelines
when some arbitrary editor over at
Twitter just says we don't really like
Ted Cruz mmm we don't really like
Michael we don't like Clavin and so they
they reduce our reach without telling us
without telling us how to do it totally
arbitrary this as jordan has presented
it is totally transparent seems like a
good idea we'll see if it works I'm I'm
hoping that it works I'm skeptical that
it will because just you you need a lot
of people there and and the fact that it
has any political agenda even if it's
Pro free speech even if it's Pro First
Amendment very possibly could get oh is
this platform but if anyone can do it
it's Jordan so let's hope that it works
other great news in social media there
is a story that people are reporting as
bad news for our politics and culture
and social media I think this is great
news and it is the rise of deep fake
videos
this is videos that look like somebody
who's recognizable as speaking but it's
just totally made on a computer listen
to this video that looks exactly like
Mark Zuckerberg imagine this for a
second one man with total control of
billions of people's stolen data all
their secrets their lives their futures
I owe it all to Spectre spectres showed
me that whoever controls the data
controls the future so Spectre is that
James Bond villainous organization
criminal organization obviously that's
not Mark Zuckerberg but it if you
haven't seen this video it looks exactly
like him and so people are saying this
is so dangerous this is going to totally
lead to all this deception and all of
this awful stuff I don't think I think
it's exactly the opposite I think that
this is going to force people to not
believe everything they see on the
internet because the the left already
twists video on the internet they twist
it outrageously you remember those
Covington kids those kids a nice kid
with the maggot hat on and he was
standing at the memorials in DC and the
media played a 20-second clip of it and
they said these kids were attacking an
elderly Indian they were costing him
they were costing black demonstrators
civil rights demonstrators and then what
happened we saw the whole video and it
was exactly the opposite but the media
used that video and spun a narrative
that's how the media can do that how
about how about Planned Parenthood
videos not only do the media and the
left take a video and and twist it to
say that it's the opposite of what it is
they'll take a video where we can see
exactly what's happening and tell us
that we can't believe our own lying eyes
they did this with an investigation into
Planned Parenthood that showed Planned
Parenthood was selling baby parts here's
the video a lot of people wanted
I was like wow I didn't even know good
for that yes there was the first section
so people wanted love
[Music]
always yeah what would you expect for it
[Music]
still they're all haggling over the
price of dead baby organs that they've
butchered and then she jokes I want a
Lamborghini ha ha ha you can see it you
can see hours of this video the
mainstream media and the left said it
was selectively edited it's don't
believe your eyes don't believe your
lying eyes
I think deep fakes are great it will
refocus people away from scandal it will
make you more skeptical it will refocus
people away from scandal I mean a good
example is with Trump you catch a
politician in some decade-old video
doing or saying something that he
shouldn't be doing and this is supposed
to end his career who can no one cares
about that no one cares what Trump said
on a bus to Billy Bush when he thought
he was having a private conversation and
having locker room talk with a guy off
you know without being miked up no one
can that doesn't affect the presidential
administration now with deep fakes
what's gonna happen is everyone's gonna
say this isn't real or you can't believe
that it's real it what it actually does
by by saying by taking away the
credibility of video we're in this video
cultural reverence being videoed all the
time by taking away the hard and
credibility of that it focuses you on
issues on the present on what's
happening now what effect will this have
on 2020 clearly the technology is
already pretty good so we'll have to see
and I can't wait for deep fake videos of
Eric's wall well something tells me they
couldn't be more ridiculous than Eric's
wall well himself we'll see about that
got more to get to but we got to get to
the mailbag so go to daily wire com 10
bucks a month hundred dollars for an
annual membership
you know you get everything you got all
the shows you get another Kingdom you
get the leftist tears tumblr that's
gonna I can't wait to have a deep fake
of Joe Biden sipping out of a delicious
leftist tears tumblr though who they'll
be there'll be his own tears there'll be
his own tears when when that commanding
lead he had starts to slip in candidates
like Liz Warren and Bernie Sanders jump
above him but we'll see we'll have to
see what happens go to daily wire.com
we'll be right back with the mailbag
the first question from Joshua Michael
why do some churches refer to God as a
she or it when he has clearly stated his
preferred pronouns are he/him and his
what are your thoughts on suing those
churches and other organizations for
purposefully misgendering God this is a
great point there are some places now a
Canada I think is one of these places
where you can be punished for not using
someone's preferred pronoun so even if a
man it's a man and the man dresses up
like a woman if you don't call him or
her you can be punished for that and
some companies and universities this is
true as well so why doesn't this apply
to God that's a great question
intersectionality has has all of these
contradictions within it you have
homosexuality and transgenderism
homosexuality relies on the belief that
there is such a thing as biological sex
and men are attracted to men and women
are attracted to women transgenderism
says sex doesn't really mean anything
it's socially constructed and men can be
women and women can be men those two
views don't go together they don't make
any sense and yet they're all together
in intersectionality transgenderism and
feminism feminism says that women are a
distinct category they're oppressed by
men women need to define what femininity
is and they need equality with men
transgenderism says there's no such
thing as men or women how do those go
together in the LGBTQ LMNOP acronym in
the left gender movement doesn't make
sense
they just unite against the oppressor
the straight white male the straight
white male who thinks that he's a male
and so you can have racial identity
politics for everybody but white people
you can have gender politics except for
straight men and I think it's the same
thing everyone gets to pick his own
gender except for God because what this
is ultimately about I mean when we're
talking about the patriarchy when we're
talking about these kind of daddy issues
and ultimately I think it redounds to
religious and metaphysical questions and
our big daddy up in the sky from Donald
I hope it's the president hello Michael
I'm a big fan of the show why is it that
through the eyes of the left this
country has become more intolerant
racist and evil in spite of all efforts
on both sides of the aisle to achieve
the opposite when did this society of
intersectional victimhood begin yes
that's true if you look around the
country we no longer have whites only
water fountains we no longer have
segregation we don't have redlining we
don't have Jim Crow
we don't have lynchings and so you buy
every objective measure the country is
more racially tolerant more racially
equitable than it was in the past and
yet people are so crazed about this they
say it's been it's more racist now than
ever
the way that this happened began in the
1960s as so many evils did and I think
what's really to blame is not the left
embracing a particular racial ideology
or the left embracing some particular
activist tactics I think it's it comes
down to this idea that they said in the
60s which is the personal is the
political so before that you had a
public realm you had the political being
a political and then you had the
personal realm and so often the media
wouldn't report on certain politicians
dalian tsa's and extramarital affairs or
whatever sort of shenanigans they were
up to because they said there's a
difference between the public and the
private you would have people who were
friends with people of opposite
political ideologies or of opposite
political parties they could go and have
fun together even though they held their
own different views because there was a
difference between the public ideas and
personalities and the personal personal
was a little different the left
shattered that in the 60s I mean this
was a slogan of there's the personal is
the political and so now the left is not
friends with conservatives very often we
see this on social media the left is
much more likely to unfriend somebody
who is of a different political point of
view then conservatives are because we
still believe in that distinction
between the personal and the public or
the political and the left doesn't our
country is never going to resolve its
political problems if we don't
reestablish that difference the left
isn't going to do it and so now it's all
personal you're a racist you're a bigot
you're an evil way
in person which you don't really see so
much from the right from Allen hey
Michael love the show what do you think
of the progressive infantilize ation in
the United States of the 18 to 21 year
old age group the greatest state of the
great state of Texas greatest perhaps
recently raise the minimum age to
purchase tobacco products to 21 and this
new law to current alcohol and gun laws
regardless of the possible health
benefits of these laws how long until
18-year olds are only seen as adults
when referencing war or legal
consequences yeah it's ridiculous it's I
don't like cigarettes I hate cigarettes
as a matter of fact you know I love
cigars very much if you can go fight and
die for your country you ought to be
able to buy a smoke this is very simple
so it's almost become a cliche argument
but it's so simple but now we want to
Infanta lies these not even late
teenagers even people who are in their
20s you see this in the criminal justice
realm as well there are there is a
movement now among criminal
psychologists to try to push up the age
at which you can be tried as a child or
some sort of child they now call you
early 20s emerging adulthood they say
your brain hasn't fully developed until
you're 25 your brain is never fully
developed you're always developing your
own brain but they say this because they
don't want 25 year olds who commit a lot
of crimes to be tried as adults they
want them to be tried as children
because ultimately they want to take
away consequences they don't want to be
in a mean culture of justice they want
to infantilized you don't to treat you
and coddle you forever and this has a
lot of political consequence to it as
well because the government that can
coddle you can treat you like a child in
other ways I think this is only getting
worse and pretty soon you're gonna have
35 year olds who are not being tried in
certain courts and who probably aren't
able to buy a pack of smokes either from
Victoria I'm Michael I'm a new
subscriber and I love the show I've been
listening to the different daily wire
show since January and I noticed you're
always the butt of the joke I've noticed
that too I've been trying to figure out
why and the best I can come up with is
that Ben is just jealous of your
best-selling blank book care to comment
thanks for all you do hash tag came for
Ben stayed for Michael thanks very nice
of you to say yes I think that is part
of it ben has written about a dozen
books in his life all with words I don't
know what he was thinking doing that and
then I wrote a book without words and I
out sold most of his but the other
reason I think I have it here is that
framed check because I bet Ben that
Trump would win in 2016 and I won so I
think you know if if I were Ben I'd be
pretty upset about that too
from laura-leigh hey Michael I love your
show and listen daily I'm so disgusted
by the news that Pinterest has banned
live action and the deceitful means by
which they tried to suppress its
pro-life message I completely deleted my
account because they've made it clear
that they can't be trusted to provide a
simple service to me in an honest way do
you think this is the best way to send a
message to these companies it is you
also have to call customer service a lot
of these companies don't have customer
service lines you need to write into
them what you need to do not just delete
your account you need to make it public
what you're doing this is how the left
makes boycotts work no one actually
boycotts anything what they do like
Media Matters and other left-wing
activist groups is they get a group of
twenty people to call a company called
Pepsi and say we're never gonna drink
Pepsi again because you advertised on
Michael's show or something like that
and they then they panic at Pepsi and
then they pull their advertising and
they change their behavior you're only
talking about ten or twenty people
calling them but that makes the
difference and it makes more of a
difference than if 200 people stopped
drinking Pepsi so it's I think you're
right to stop using that platform but
even if you keep using the platform you
go back to it sometimes or whatever the
key here is to make public how you're
dropping them if you drop Netflix over
it's abortion activism more important
than cutting Netflix more important than
deleting your account because I think
there are only seven people in America
who actually pay for Netflix and all the
rest of us are just stealing their
passwords more important than that is
you have to call customer service and
let them know how upset you are with how
they're treating conservatives from
Ashley hey Michael on the conversation
of gender equality differences and
religion do you think there's a moral
difference between male and female
miscue 'ti a lot of people especially
parents seem more concerned with female
promiscuity Thanks I don't think there's
a moral difference between male and
female promiscuity but there is a
difference especially in the case of
cheating for instance there's a there's
a difference in the sense that men view
sex differently than women men view sex
you know in a more physical gratifying
way it is certainly the case that men
can have casual sex more casually than
women do because women tend to attach
some emotional significance to sex part
of this is biological because women have
a lot more to lose part of this as
spiritual or even just practical women
have a lot more to lose from sex than
men - maybe men develop some sort of
ailment and they need to go get a cream
from their doctor or something women can
become pregnant and also because women
are the weaker sex physically they are
weaker they need there are certain
protections that they need that men
don't need whether those are social or
political there were or a matter of
regulation so I do think there is a
physical difference and this is why as a
society we treat male and female
promiscuity differently but I think when
we all get up to st. Peter's gate we're
probably all going to have to answer for
it equally from Ryan
greetings Michael I hope that this
message won't hurt your YouTube video do
you think the reason for this crackdown
on YouTube started by the Vox ad
pocalypse
is because it has successful the daily
wire ladder with Crowder blaze TV and
Prager you have become compared to
left-wing groups like The Young Turks
Vox and Huffington Post I remember
Crowder saying something about how
YouTube actually helps the Young Turks
advertise and produce or something along
those lines to help make their show less
terrible why don't more people talk
about how YouTube has tried to promote
the Young Turks over the Daily wire yes
that is largely what this is about
so the write is just better at the
Internet we're much better at it we're
more popular on the internet we're
funnier at it the reason is we were kept
out of the mainstream mainstream
Hollywood mainstream news media and so
you've got a whole buildup of talent and
ideas
and strategies and we've worked and
figured out how to get our message out
there and we're just better at it The
Young Turks has produced their show in
YouTube's own studios and their show is
still terrible and YouTube itself is
giving them support and it's still
absolutely terrible so a lot of what
you're seeing now from the left lobbying
YouTube and other tech companies is they
say you need to suppress provocative
unreliable fake news sites and by that
they just mean conservatives and you
need to boost authoritative sources and
of course the authoritative sources are
they themselves so there's a an
ideological struggle here but then it's
just a matter of economics they can't
compete with us in the open market
because we're much better at this than
they are so they're trying to get the
corporation's themselves to go and
suppress us kill off their competition
and unfairly boost them and and that's
part of the illogical part of it is cold
hard cash that's our show have a good
weekend more to get to we'll get to it
on Monday in the meantime I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 hey everyone
its Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew
Clavin show the mainstream media and
social media aren't labeling ben shapiro
and dave rubin alt-right extremists by
accident it's part of a strategy to
silence conservative voices and ensure
Donald Trump's 2020 defeat I told you it
was gonna happen I'm telling you it's
happening and I'll tell you more about
it on the Andrew Klavan show I'm Andrew
Clavin